- Groundhog day, Super Bowl.
Seventh Super Bowl for the
Patriots, and this new regime,
I always have to clarify that
now, because it's actually
Patriot knucklehead fans who
come out and say "oh we're
"nine, '85 Bears, and then
we lost to the Packers."
I'm talking about the regime,
I'm talking Belichick,
Brady, this particular regime
being the greatest sports'
dynasty of all time.
It was a blowout, Patriots
won easy, Falcons won easy.
So interesting game for the
Super Bowl, listen, I watched
the game, it was methodical,
there was never any doubt,
I don't think there's any
way the Patriots lose to
the Falcons, I close my
eyes try to imagine it,
I try to think, how can the
Falcons beat the Patriots?
I don't think there is a
chance, I don't know what's
gonna happen, the Falcons if
they weren't, this is gonna
sound weird, if the Falcons
weren't the Falcons--
- Yeah that's the biggest
problem, the biggest problem
with this team is that
they're the Atlanta Falcons..
- Right, so having said
that, they're a good team,
and it almost in a weird way
reminds me of the Arizona
Cardinals who lost to the
Steelers, and the Steelers are--
- You're not gonna beat them.
- Yeah, Larry Fitzgerald had
a huge game, and they were
very good, and maybe better,
I don't know what happens here
but I know the Patriots are
gonna win, and I'm gonna
get my revenge on Roger
Godell, with a crowd of Patriot
fans, which to be honest,
the more I think about it,
I don't know how part of that
vendetta, that mob scene,
of people trying to just
assassinate Roger Godell,
I mean what can you say?
Both games stunk,
absolute stunk.
- It was not enjoyable to watch.
- And this whole season seems
like a forgone conclusion
for the Patriots to
win the Super Bowl.
- Every year, especially as
a Patriot's hater, it's every
year I just assume it's
going to happen, and when it
doesn't, that's the surprise,
that's where it's at.
- I agree with the name of the
Atlanta Falcons, kind of like
the Tampa Bay Rays,
you just can't ever,
you know what I mean?
(talking over each other)
The Diamond Backs have won a
World Series, but you're still
like "the Diamond Backs."
The Falcons though, they
are a very exciting team,
that offense is like a video
game, I know you're not
worried at all Dave, I know
you're gonna say any time
I try to say "you know, this
team actually has some talent,"
they do have talent, the
defense has come on, I mean they
shut out Aaron Rogers
in the first half.
That was legit, you don't
just do that like by accident.
And Matt Ryan is playing out
of his mind, Julio Jones,
Julio Jones is gonna be the
best player on the field
in my mind on Super Bowl Sunday.
- Better than Tom Brady?
- At their current state, yes.
- The problem though, is
that the Patriots will just
have someone step up and
play like Julio Jones,
like Chris fucking Martin!
It doesn't matter who the
stars are, the Patriots just
always fucking do it anyway.
- I just gotta do a callback
here to what you just,
Tom Brady's playing as
well as he's ever played,
and he's arguably the
best player of all time.
- Julio Jones is making
plays and running like a,
the plays he makes, I don't
know how anyone could ever
guard him, I'm just saying.
That's one man's opinion, I
know you're obviously on Patriot
mode right now.
- I feel like the last
week it was Aaron Rogers
versus Tom Brady, and then
like Rogers gets shut out
and we just forget we
had that conversation.
Julio Jones is a great
player, but Brady is playing
as well as he's ever played,
he is the best player
of all time.
- Any time Tom Brady steps
on the football field
he is the most influential
player of that game,
no matter who he's
facing up against.
- Yeah, that's probably fair.
Julio Jones, I haven't
seen, the stuff Julio Jones
is doing is like--
- I also like to say Belichick--
- That's the difference,
it's probably because Brady's
been doing it for so long,
and it's the same Brady,
Julio Jones is doing shit,
and I'm like "holy fuck,
"how is this guy catching
balls at the same pace?"
- I agree he's a great
player, but there's also,
we're actually doing it
because, I know people are like
"oh I'm not really thinking
about that, I'm thinking about
"just, I'm so convinced the
Patriots are gonna win this
"game, I can't imagine
a scenario they
don't, because it's
"the Atlanta Falcons."
But X's and O's wise, we will
take Julio Jones out of the
game, like the Patriots take
your best offensive player
and somebody else is gonna
have to beat the Patriots.
- Yeah, and the Falcons have
all their guys, I mean some
of the guys, Coleman,
he's lie another guy who's
been making plays, you're
like "holy shit, this guy
"is a video game."
- Quick shout out to the stoolie
who pulled the fire alarm
on the Steelers.
And then we got an email
that they were talking about
all day, we got the police
report of him getting arrested.
That quote "I'm dumb, I'm
drunk, and I'm a Pat's fan."
- And I love it, and
to be honest, I think
that's fair game.
I think pulling fire alarms
when you're on the road.
In the Super Bowl, we guarded
the Patriot's fire alarm
because it got pulled twice.
If you don't want your fire
alarms pulled, get home field
advantage, and by the way,
don't let people find out
where you're staying, so
shout out to that guy,
tip of the cap.
He did get arrested, I don't
know what's gonna happen,
but they should send
him to the Super Bowl.
Good job by him, I don't know
if you guys feel that way
or not, but I want to give
him a shine since they sent
us the police report.
Moving on, away from the
Super Bowl, and there will be
a lot of Patriot talk.
By the way, the
Falcons have no fans.
I did this on the serious
show, even the fans were like,
any Falcons fans call in,
they didn't even call in,
we had the number one like
Falcon Atlanta radio show
host, Ryan Finneran,
we had him call in.
He was so boring, he
couldn't even get excited.
If I was saying these things
that people are saying Atlanta,
I'm like "it's the worst
city, no fans, they only have
"strip clubs, it's a
franchise nobody cares about,"
they're like "yeah
you may be right."
I mean that's who
we're dealing with.